today is a very special day it's the
birthday of none other than Levy Rosman
also known as Gotham chess and I thought
in celebration of his birthday I'll be
sharing a match that we played a few
weeks ago it was a three-game blitz
match and things got pretty brutal
towards the end uh I don't want to spoil
too much but the final game ended in
just 10 moves and one of us got hurt
pretty badly so hope you enjoyed the
chess if you're watching this on
November 5th wish love you a happy
birthday if you're watching this
sometime in the future you can wish him
a belated birthday and enjoy the video
I could just listen into Levy's stream
but last time I listened into Levy
stream it wasn't so family friendly
anyway that's what I've seen
and you know it starts from a very like
young age and it only gets worse oh
we're playing I mean just watch watch my
podcast with Anna kramling how she gets
okay let me let me Focus here
where's my thing there's my thing okay
I'm not prepared for this also why am I
stream sniping
close out of twitch
we've played this before he plays this
um n86 is a fine move
um
and I'm not like in the mental state to
play Levy right now
but he's probably not in the mental
state to play me like he was waiting for
his movie
okay so yeah I'm just trying to make my
pieces happy
there's a lot of improving moves
oh D5
oh my washing machine is singing I was
doing laundry earlier
that sings to me when it's finished
okay so I have a isolated Queen's Pawn
never mind
the very short-lived iqp
of
F4 a queen B6 is coming
I don't know what my Knight's doing here
hey bishop B3
probably wants to move to E4 but then
Pawn would drop
maybe Queen E2
hi Eric lots of love
hi your brother
appreciate the the brotherly love
how is Levy's reading so high wow lovey
has a high rating
or a retired person
okay so the bishop actually might want
to go to C2 and like Target the king
a night before Bishop B1
I could play A3
it's an interesting move
another move I really wanted to play but
I think I want to keep these squares
controlled
yeah I'm thinking Knight E4 now
although
I'm not sure
[Music]
I'm just trading Queens
go get her Merrick I'm trying I'm trying
I'm trying
A4 is attached
getting some endgame
Knight's a little bit misplaced F4 can
come
and very prophylactic play
Rick wants to come to C1
foreign
yeah
H3 is hanging
or was it poisonous
what
wow
what is this
hurt me
oh no my Rook
oh my time
and my king
oh
can we do one more
uh I guess we do one more okay
time for Revenge
uh let's play this move
now let's play this move
this is game one of our match
of our uh I'm not a GM match
do you played this and I played this or
no he played this I think
I wonder what he's talking about right
now
I'm tempted to stream snipe oh he
probably got a smoothie right oh oh this
is [ __ ] yummy yeah this is good stuff
oh this is unreated oh I can't Farm him
and he can't find me so
I guess we're not Farmers today
I wonder if he's he knows about this
line
I prepared this line specifically for
him
never ended up like playing it against
him and then this line was featured in
like a lot of top level games recently
I think everyone
played this with Olympian
I mean we could have gone into this our
first game in the match
B1 signing up for the next game it's
move nine white has all the pieces on
their starting swears
that's so funny
is E4
I played D3
I feel like D3 is one of these like
weird engine moves
it might just work
also I feel like I've studied this
before I maybe studying the position
after E3 D3
with the following E4 it should be even
better for lack
because there's this move
and The Bishop's stuck it's still a
question how to
exploit things
like Bishop C5
it looks really really good
G3 may be coming G3 may be this idea H3
he's gonna play H3 um
how to punish White
bro
it's time to Rook lift
wow look at this Rook lift I feel so
muscular
bro
wait how do I meet
I want a funny mate
I take uh Queen h8
of
Bishop
I mean everything should be winning
I'm ready to take on A2 and Bishop B3
checkmate
what a funny position
to lead bong cloud
uh he's attacking my thing
I can take
this
as pawn and D3 is such a MVP
Bishop F7
[Music]
I just want a funny mate
some
I mean queen C2 is almost a threat
or G hates the thread okay oh that was a
nice game
okay can I say uh last game chat
disabled
uh where's my chat settings
uh
game shot
friends only
everyone are we not friends
refresh oh maybe he has chat disabled
uh is he gonna play the Stafford against
me
no
okay let me play a Halloween
if he wants it no no Halloween
oh there's a game today between Eric
Hansen and uh Dominguez
and Eric got into some trouble
but it's not quite the same line
I have no idea if this is theory
it looks cool though
wow
oh the weird opening
I take on F6
I want to take with a knight
take take let's do it
we're having some fun here
it's actually kind of cool because take
six I play E5
did Eric I forgot
I have this move though
he was probably so excited Castle
I did Overlook it but
uh
or Knight T5 are the two legal moves
Rook F7 there's Knight G5
or Levy
a 10 move game
that was my last game too
I feel kind of bad